do you have any tips for our viewers on  how to make christmas queer this year  um oh uh  oh gosh how could you make christmas  great i mean christmas is already pretty  damn camp like it is  um get as much tinsel as you can i don't  know if you call it that in america but  do you know what tinsel is okay okay  um  yeah so get as much tinsel as you can  bake something fabulous what's a great  british baking show and queer um and  yeah just embrace the the culture of the  holidays it's the campus thing i love  christmas  i love christmas too i love queer eye  season six was fantastic congratulations  on that congratulations on the outerwear  line and i'm gonna snag myself something  maybe in the next drop yeah something  before it goes we've still got some  things available online get something  thank you so much  thank you thank you